since a little like gym sock a pretty
woman's armpit vacants of feminism do I
sound like idiots smells like dinner
with my parents
it smells like dinner with Henry's
parents full smoky yeah
that's a good word for that's really
poetic a little smoky this is close to
like just grape juice just Welch's yeah
I could really get drunk on this I just
keep going yeah it doesn't even taste
like wine because this one is easier to
go down I feel like it's more expensive
yeah I'll say like 25 bucks on this one
three dollars Walgreens wise 1199 forty
dollars oh hey yellowtail you're doing
something right y'all tell all day every
day
oh yeah that's different that smells
much more like white I don't like this
one as much
this is nice fruity whoa whoa these
wines they just we really taste like
something you'd pour on a cut I would
pay good money for this I'm gonna go
with $12 $35 that feels like a $6 tjs
wine this is older than some people who
work here there's a lot cooler things
you can buy with 150 bucks like probably
a used Nintendo DS when you know
something's expensive it tastes way
better
oh it smell sweeter maybe a little
floral I'm making that up
like everybody makes up words when
they're tasting wine mm-hmm there's like
very little bite to it this one I could
see myself spending a little bit more on
I would get a glass of this at like TGI
Fridays I think this is a Riesling
that's $25 30 40 bucks a bottle
I'm gonna say $12 cuz it barefoot it's
barefoot barefoot Chardonnay
I love barefoot why are you hating on
all the cheap just because they come at
a good price this is why you're naughty
I'm not Haiti can you it for 50 get new
it hmm
yeah this is really good this is Pinot
Noir yes hello friend is it wrong for me
to say that it's kind of sexy and I
think there's like a hint of both fruit
and oak to them Oh food milk it's only
it's always fruit and oak with you yeah
that's why I'm talk I think it tastes
like tree leaves
I'm gonna say $3 $30 $22 $57 whoa yeah
I'm soaking classing you guys oh I'm
just like a classy [ __ ] how can you
possibly say that when you're sitting
here with purple hair
hey I just really don't know wine I
drink it every day and obviously cannot
tell one from the other because it just
just just drink some wine with you just
forgetting dumb it if you like it you
like it Jeremy this is pretty well we
nailed it people think I'm all edgy but
I'm also classes sorry can I take a step
back I don't think anybody has ever said
classy as has been classy